[Música]
al final las acusaciones en su contra no
hicieron la diferencia ahmed naser al
raíz y fue elegido presidente de
interpol con el 69% de los votos
emitidos por los países miembros de la
agencia policial internacional se han
presentado varias denuncias de tortura y
detención arbitraria contra el general
quien hasta ahora es el jefe de las
fuerzas de seguridad de emiratos árabes
unidos- entre quienes lo acusan estando
ciudadanos británicos quienes llegaron
el lunes a estambul donde se ha estado
celebrando la asamblea general de
interpol
como puede alguien como el general al
rais y que está a cargo como inspector
general de prisiones guardias e
interrogadores cómo puede alguien así
convertirse en jefe de la interpol
en junio fue presentada otra acusación
en francia dice que raíz y es
responsable de la tortura de la
activista de mirat y ahmed mansur quien
ha permanecido en una celda de 4 metros
cuadrados durante los últimos cuatro
años el mes pasado diecinueve ongs
expresaron su preocupación por la
candidatura de raíz y lo describieron
como parte de un aparato de seguridad
que ataca sistemáticamente a los
críticos pacíficos entretanto los
emiratos árabes unidos han invertido
significativamente en interpol durante
los últimos años en 2007 donaron casi lo
mismo de lo que se requería en total por
concepto de contribuciones de los 195
países miembros